the vaping epidemic may have taken a
deadly turn Illinois is reporting the
first possible death in the United
States linked to e-cigarette smoking the
death comes as federal health officials
are investigating nearly 200 cases of
severe lung illnesses among vapors and a
Warner has the story concerns over
health risks associated with vaping came
home to roost when an adult in Illinois
who recently used e-cigarettes died from
an unexplained pulmonary illness it's
one of 22 cases recently reported in
Illinois most involving men between the
ages of 17 and 38 some of them admitted
to using THC an ingredient in marijuana
while vaping now public health officials
are investigating 193 possible cases of
severe lung illness associated with
vaping in 22 states all of them reported
since June 28th dr. Emily Chapman is
chief medical officer at Children's
Minnesota hospitals where they have had
15 confirmed or suspected cases we can
say that we're seeing a pattern of lung
injury that we have not seen before 1
the chest x-ray the whole thing looks
abnormal and it looks abnormal equally
throughout the entire lung it's still
not clear which product or substances
many of those individuals used 18
year-old chance a Murata florida wound
up in the ER after using e-cigarettes
his doctor believes his vaping may have
contributed to a lung injury I just
freaked out and they said your lung has
collapsed you have to go to surgery
right now
the American vaping Association takes
the position that its THC or illegal
drugs that are to blame for these acute
lung injuries but health authorities say
they're still investigating they're
still looking to see if there's a common
thread that ties these cases together
nationwide for CBS this morning Saturday
and a werner chicago so scary i talked
with the doctor yesterday over on CBS n
about this and really one of the biggest
concerns obviously is with teenagers and
young smokers because they seem to be
seeing even more cases those lungs are
still developing and it's just not good
for that such mixed messaging yeah for
kids there they're told it's better than
cigarette
at the same time we don't have all of
the information and just like knowing
what's in it yeah yeah that's exactly
yeah